Southwest Jets back in the year today
full schedule that's about 3 900 flights
only six Southwest flights arriving into
Las Vegas were canceled today no
departures this is a huge Improvement
since earlier this week when more than
15 000 Southwest flights canceled across
the U.S as Madison Kimbrough reports
Travelers so glad to get flying once
again
finally as passengers tell me they are
ecstatic to be back home here in Las
Vegas some even visiting for the New
Year's Eve holiday oh my it feels
amazing to be home I told my mom as long
as we get four seats to Vegas that's all
I want Akash Abraham and his family back
home after a long stressful week on the
East Coast visiting family in North
Carolina for Christmas they were finally
able to make it back today flying Delta
Delta couldn't put us on any of their
flights because whatever seats they may
have had was all taken by the ones that
we're flying with Southwest trying to
get to Vegas Southwest customers
Christina and Michael flew into Las
Vegas from California to celebrate the
new year but they almost thought they
would make it because of this week's
chaos we bought tickets to the 49er
Raider game and we would have been out
you know two thousand dollars a little
concern because of all the flights
canceled before we'd even call the
airline and they reassured us that by
Friday they'll be caught up and we
should have any problems as for luggage
delays it depends on the airlines as
several are moving along nicely while
Southwest unfortunately still is
efforting to get bags to its owners as
you can still see hundreds of bags
behind me reporting in Harry Reid
International Airport Madison Kimbrough
8 News Now